o sea muchas gracias por atendernos y le
pregunto primero cómo se logró esta
victoria de derechos humanos y cómo
serán resarcidos los afectados muy
buenas tardes daniele gracias por la
invitación pues en este caso llega a la
corte porque estas siete personas con el
acompañamiento de la clínica jurídica de
la universidad de los andes presentaron
una tutela que fue negada en primera y
segunda instancia pero fue seleccionada
por la corte constitucional luego de
prueba que también se solicitará
formalmente que la seleccionará la corte
entonces revisó este caso y como tú
decías consideró que en el procedimiento
de expulsión se vulneraron las garantías
del debido proceso el derecho a la
dignidad humana y a la unidad familiar y
entonces le ordenó tomar medidas muy
concretas en este caso la primera de
ellas es que debe repetir el
procedimiento sancionatorio migratorio
es decir que la orden de expulsión queda
suspendida hasta que nuevamente se haga
el procedimiento con garantizando pues
que se para que se cumplan las medidas
del debido proceso que se tenga en
cuenta la situación particular de estas
siete personas y el impacto que una
decisión como ésta podría tener en la
unidad familiar y en los derechos de los
niños y niñas de los cuales ellos estas
personas pues son responsables o que
habían dejado en colombia si una vez la
corte determina que no hay motivación
para el haberse dado esta expulsión debe
revocar la decisión y además deberá
ofrecer disculpas públicas tanto la
policía como migración colombia a las
personas afectadas por esta vulneración
de derechos sin luz y ahí cree que éste
podría hacer una muestra más de la
creciente xenofobia contra los
ciudadanos venezolanos y además como se
combatiría este fenómeno creciente
definitivamente digamos a nosotros nos
preocupa mucho cómo se está utilizando
la medida de expulsión no solamente en
este caso sino en otros casos como lo
muestran cifras que hemos publicado en
nuestra página web
siempre digamos en el contexto tan
particular que sucedió este caso que fue
en el marco del paro nacional de 2019
donde se estaba buscando un chivo chivo
expiatorio para justificar muchas de las
acciones que se estaban presentando
durante estos días nos preocupa el
mensaje que desde las autoridades está
dando al acusar a estas personas de
haber participado en los disturbios de
ese día sin tener las pruebas
suficientes y esto obviamente incrementa
los sentimientos de xenofobia de la
ciudadanía y en general esperamos que
este fallo mande un mensaje muy claro a
la necesidad de que se garanticen todas
las medidas y el debido proceso en estos
procedimientos sancionatorios
migratorios pero además también que se
restablezca el derecho a la honra y al
buen nombre de estas siete personas